well the editor of the Christian Post is
quitting all because the publication
took a stance and defended president
Trump after another Christian magazine
called for his removal I warned them I
said if if you go down this road and
join Team Trump then that will destroy
the reputation of the Christian Post and
I was told that that that is the
direction that they want to go and at
that point you know we had reached an
impasse and I really had no other choice
but to leave did have another choice but
joining me now is Rachel Campos Duffy a
Fox News contributor Rachel when you saw
this story read about it and heard this
gentleman's comments what did you think
I thought he was just totally out of
step with where evangelicals are
evangelicals are 77 percent approval for
Donald Trump
and among those 77 percent the majority
of them don't just approve of Donald
Trump they strongly approve of Donald
Trump it's not that they love Donald
Trump or they or they love the
president's tweets or they love his
colorful past that's not it at all they
love the policies and they realize that
he is the best and most fearless
defender of all the things that they
believe in whether it's their pro-life
position school choice even Christian
persecution both in the United States
and abroad he's he stepped up on Israel
man go on and on in all these positions
that they've taken that Christian and
evangelicals and conservatives in
general really love and that's what that
the publication was was defending not
Donald Trump but his policies well it
really at the heart of this if as best I
understand this story was the position
on impeachment that how clear it was or
unclear some people want to see the
President and impeach the others did not
so want to see him impeached I respect
the right of religions to be able to
speak out and take positions on this is
that simply what he's doing here or is
this a bridge too far where he's going
out and saying I mean he's putting his
money where his mouth is right by
quitting and saying I can't
anymore right and to be fair he said
listen if this had come out as an op-ed
I'm all for it he was upset that the
publication published this as an
editorial basically saying this is the
position of the of the entire
publication and but again I think that
it's an evangelical publication and they
are reflecting the views of so many
evangelicals and many evangelicals
conservatives and Catholics people of
faith really believe that the the
president is being persecuted primarily
and I believe so much of politics in
America is about abortion so it is the
Supreme Court it is all the judges that
he's appointed at the federal level this
is what really I think is animating the
left is animating this impeachment
process at it's very root and people
don't talk about that much they want to
talk about Ukraine and they want to talk
about you know the Russia hoax or talk
about all these other things but at the
root of so much in American politics is
abortion and that is an issue that
evangelicals do have a stake and they
are very pleased with what the president
has done in terms of of nominating
judges and really setting up the Supreme
Court to to take very constitutional
positions and also a position of life
and defending life at a constitutional
level yeah and I do wish everybody would
go back and hear what the president said
in front of the United Nations probably
one of the most important in impactful
speeches on religious liberties I think
no matter where you are in the religious
spectrum what the President of the
United States was doing in front of the
UN that was a great speech and he never
got enough credit for it I hope people
can go back and watch it Rachel Campos
Duffy merry Christmas to you and your
family that big wonderful family I I
wish them both nothing but the best but
thank you so much for joining us